I've been trying to make enough money
for my wife to love me even though she
didn't ask for that I was trying to make
enough money and have enough security so
my son would feel safe like I didn't
growing up
he didn't ask for that what I was really
trying to do was to get somebody to tell
me John you got value
and they were I just couldn't hear it
because I was running it so hard right
and so rock bottom for me was
oh you don't like you
and I think most of us If we're honest
we go to the mirror and we don't like
what we see man we don't like who we are
rightly or wrongly we don't like us and
so why in the world would you change the
way you eat
if why would you spend a bunch of money
taking care of your car when you hate
the car
why would you put good gas in that car
if you hate that car why would you put
nice tires in that car why would you
take it to the best mechanic you won't
it's just a dumb car
and I think we think of ourselves that
way and so for me Rock Bottom was
opening my eyes and being like no no
you're worth being loved too